[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à ceux qui ont des
croyances
bonsoir à ceux qui ont des convictions
bonsoir à ceux pour qui c'est très
simple je vais t'expliquer bonsoir à
ceux qui ne comprennent pas comment il
ne peut pas comprendre une chose aussi
simple
bonsoir au simplificateur à ceux qui
réduisent une personne un seul aspect de
sa personnalité à ceux qui réduisent
l'explication d'un phénomène à une ou
deux causes bien trouvé bref je crois
avoir salué tout le monde alors bonsoir
à toutes et à tous
ce soir je vous parlerai de pensée
complexe plus encore je réfléchirai ou
du moins je tenterai de vous soumettre
quelques propositions afin de réfléchir
à la question suivante comment passer de
la pensée complexe à l'action afin
d'illustrer mon propos autorisé mois la
métaphore suivante il en est de l'action
comme d'un vol en avion
celle ci est réussi lorsqu'elle est bien
préparée
en effet un vol en avion comporte deux
phases qui correspondent à celles de
l'action le décollage puis le vol en soi
mais également toute une phase en amont
qui est une phase de préparation
on effectue un certain nombre de
contrôles on vérifie que les taux de
kérosène sont bons contre les moteurs et
tout cela tous ces contrôles
correspondent à cette phase avant
l'action qui correspond à la pensée car
comme nous le disait edgar morin
l'action est un art et son seul viatique
et de bien penser alors qu'est-ce que
bien pensés pour edgar morin vous vous
en doutez bien pensé c'est avant tout
pensée complexe comment complexifier
votre pensée comme en partant de
quelques croyances quelques idées
parvenir à les complexifier complexifier
sa pensée nécessite de résister à une
tentation forte une tentation
simplificatrice qui est celle du
réductionnisme le réductionnisme
ces deux choses tout d'abord réduire l'
explication d'un phénomène où la
connaissance que vous avez d'une
personne à une ou deux dimensions et
ainsi développer une vision partielle
une vision unidimensionnelle intel par
exemple et comme ceci
après tout si nous avons des problèmes
c'est à cause de la croissance
explication exclusivement économiques ou
d'autres exclusivement sociologique
c'est à cause de tel groupe social
réduire l'explication la compréhension à
une seule cause complexifier sa pensée
consiste à dépasser cela allait chercher
explorer d'autres dimensions à passer
d'une vision unidimensionnelle à une
pensée multidimensionnelle là où vous ne
voyez par exemple pour expliquer la
réussite ou non d'une entreprise que des
causes économiques aller chercher des
causes sociologiques historiques
politiques
là où vous n'expliquez une personne
intel est comme ceux ci comme cela qu
avec des éléments psychologiques aller
chercher des éléments sociologiques
biologique
bref enrichir votre pensée en partant à
la quête d'autres dimensions possibles
et ainsi vous résisterez à ce premier
réductionnisme qui est le fait de
réduire à une seule dimension passer
d'une pensée unidimensionnel à une
pensée multidimensionnelle le deuxième
réductionnisme est celui de réduire une
personne ou l'explication d'un phénomène
à votre seul et unique point de vue le
philosophe alain nous disaient penser
c'est dire non qui se contente de sa
pensée ne pense plus rien il vous compte
et pas de votre point de vue il est
insuffisant il fera de votre
connaissance de votre croyance de votre
compréhension et de votre pensée une
affaire très partiale qui ne dépend que
de votre parti pris que de votre point
de vue avoue complexifier sa pensée
avoir le souci de pensée complexe
nécessite de partir à la quête d'autres
points de vue possibles d'autres façons
de voir d'envisager des phénomènes des
personnes je vous invite donc à passer
d'une vision très unie point de vue un
seul point de vue à la pluralisation des
points de vue à la quête d'autres points
de vue possibles
en faisant cela vous résisterez donc à
ce double réductionnisme réduire vos
connaissances votre croyance votre
compréhension à une seule dimension mais
également le fait de la réduire à votre
seul point de vue
vous retrouverez alors avec un ensemble
d'informations un ensemble de
connaissances de point de vue d'
éléments de connaissance qui vous
permettront de mieux pensé et tous ces
éléments il s'agira pour vous de les
relier deux les tisser ensemble ce
qu'edgar morin appelle la reliance fait
de relier des dimensions entre elles des
points de vue entre eux alors évidemment
au moment où je vous dis cela
la première tentation serait avec tous
ses points de vue toutes ses dimensions
de tenter d'établir une synthèse
chercher des complémentarités en faisant
cela vous continuerez à simplifier la
complexification consiste à relier deux
manières dialogique c'est à dire en
tenant compte à la fois des
complémentarités possibles qui
permettent d'établir des synthèses mais
tout en maintenant les antagonismes les
paradoxes insurmontable il est des
points de vue des dimensions qui ne se
réconcilie pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas
entretenir de relations de
complémentarité et il faut les voir les
reconnaître et enfin la panse et
dialogique c'est aussi de considérer le
fait que certaines dimensions certains
points de vue peuvent être en
concurrence en lutte
une dimension la dimension sociologique
ou politiques cherchant à prendre le
dessus sur la dimension économique et il
s'agit à chaque fois de les envisager
relié de manière complexe
c'est donc relié en pensant à la fois
les complémentarités et paradoxes
insurmontable mais également les
logiques de concurrence et 11 ans
là vous retrouverez face au phénomène de
la complexité
vous retrouverez bien incapable si je
vous demandais de parler d'un tel en
effectuant tout ce travail de
complexification vous seriez bien
incapable de parler tout ce que vous
sauriez dire c'est que c'est très
complexe
alors que faire que dire
paul valéry nous disait que ce qui est
simple et fo si vous étiez contenter de
votre idée première sans ce travail de
complexification vous auriez eu tort
vous seriez tropez ce qui est simple et
fo ce qui est compliqué et inutilisable
alors que faire la première possibilité
d'abandonner de vous résignez de ne rien
faire de rester dans votre mode de
pensée de vous dire ce doute manière
beaucoup trop complexe ne faisons rien
ou pire continuons à faire comme
d'habitude c'est la première possibilité
la possibilité d fatigué et désespérée
des résignés l'autre possibilité c'est
celle que je vous propose
et non pas d'abandonner l'action mais de
la repenser non pas de vous dire que
vous avez besoin de certitudes pour agir
mais d'être capable d'agir malgré
l'incertitude est ainsi d'envisager vos
actions comme des paris agir en tenant
compte de la complexité agir de manière
complexe c'est faire un pari c'est faire
le pari de l'action et toute action est
un pari alors quand anton par paris le
pari est une décision à un moment vous
avez tout un ensemble d'informations de
point de vue de dimension vous allez
devoir choisir décider trancher va
falloir se mouiller jouer sa peau se
lancer c'est une décision
modeste une décision modeste car vous
savez que vous ne pourrez pas tenir
compte de tous les points de vue valide
car vous savez que vous ne pourrez pas
prendre en compte toutes les dimensions
qui pourtant sont pertinentes car vous
savez que vous ne savez pas tout grandes
maladies de penser savoir quand on ne
sait pas cette illusion d'illusions de
savoir de penser savoir tout cela vous
le savez que l'incertitude demeure
alors on reste modeste
un pari est une décision modeste
politique
vous choisissez lorsque vous pariez de
favoriser un certain nombre de points de
vue par rapport à d'autres un certain
nombre de dimensions politique
économique sociale par rapport à
d'autres et dès lors que vous choisissez
de donner plus de pouvoirs à une
dimension plutôt qu'à une autre à
certains points de vue plus d'eau qu'à
d'autres
alors votre décision devient choix
politique et toute décision est
politique
tout paris et politiques toutes actions
et politiques
il n'y a pas d'action neutre
politiquement il n'y a pas de choix
neutre ou apolitiques toute action étant
un pari c'est à la fois une décision
modeste politique mais le propre du pari
c'est qu'on l'aimait que dans l'espoir
de réussir ce que l'on veut c'est que ça
marche
ce n'est pas un pari de cyniques qui
aimait son pari et keith diouf en pis si
ça marche pas non c'est un pari
courageux et pour que ça marche
de la même manière que une fois en vol
une fois dans les airs le pilote
continue à rester vigilants à rester
prudent à accueillir les informations à
les collecter
pour que ça marche il vous faudra
continuer durant le vol à faire preuve
de ce qu'edgar morin appelle la
stratégie
l'action est un art son seul viatique et
de bien penser lorsqu'il utilise la
notion d'art
il renvoie à l'art de la stratégie l'art
de collecter des informations
l'art de lutter contre le hasard l'art
de saisir les opportunités qui se
présentent à vous l'art de faire preuve
de créativité lardeux
continuez à penser en agissant de
continuer à penser de manière complexe
tout en agissant collecter d'autres
points de vue sur ce qu'il se passe
collectez identifier d'autres dimensions
que vous n'auriez pas vu ou analyser
voilà ce qu'est l'art de la stratégie de
l'action dans la complexité
alors évidemment tout cela implique une
certaine dose de courage
cela implique de lutter lutter contre
vos croyances facile contre vos préjugés
contre nos convictions un peu lâche de
lutter contre l'autojustification le
mensonge à soi même
cet orgueil cet ego qui parfois nous
empêche de voir cela implique de lutter
et d'avoir le souci de lutter contre
l'illusion l'erreur le mensonge la
fausseté tout cela implique d'être dans
une lutte permanente et c'est dans cette
lutte et je crois profondément que dans
cette lutte permanente c'est dans cette
lutte permanente que nous vivons que
nous sommes vivants comme nous le disait
victor hugo dans ces quelques vers qui
me serviront de conclusion ceux qui
vivent ce sont ceux qui luttent ce sont
ceux dont un dessein ferme emplit l'âme
et le front
ce qui d'un os désiste ingrat vis seul
après sim ce qui marche pensif qui
marchent pensif 1 ne restent pas assis
tout en pensant comme l'écrivait michel
audiard deux intellectuels à civaux
moins long moins loin qu'une grue qui
marche ce qui marche pensif et prix d'un
but sublime ceux dont le coeur est bon
modeste responsable courageux ceux dont
le coeur est bon ce dont les jours sont
pleins et avec le programme de
complexification de la pensée vaujour
croyez-moi seront pleins ceux dont le
coeur est bon ce dont les jours sont
plaints cela vive mesdames et messieurs
les autres je les plains car de son
vague ennuis le néant les ans neeve et
méfiez vous du néant
hannah arendt nous disait c'est dans le
vide de la pensée que s'inscrit le mal
est fait vous de ce néant de la pensée
car de son vague ennuis du néant les en
livre
car le plus lourd fardeau mesdames et
messieurs le plus lourd fardeau
c'est d'exister sans vivre merci
[Applaudissements]